[موسيقى]
الولاء عميق في شيكاغو
، تتشكل الولاءات خلال فترة الطفولة
وغالبًا ما تملي الأحياء المكان الذي
تسقط فيه البيتزا ، السياسة الرياضية ، اختر المعسكر
والالتزام به ، لم يعد
عليّ الآن أن أتجنب روميتش نفسي في
الموضوع الجاد لطبق بيتزا شيكاغو.
أو على طراز الحانة الرقيقة
وقد أتيت من وسط المدينة إلى
الأحياء الشمالية ، يتطلب الأمر تفاخرًا حقيقيًا في
شيكاغو لتسمي نفسك
بفن
البيتزا ، وسأحصل على شريحة من ذلك وشريحة من
القشرة الرقيقة
[موسيقى]
أعتقد ذلك  حوالي نصف الشفرة
ولم يتم تسجيل ربعها تقريبًا الآن في
أمريكا ، فأنت تأكل البيتزا بأصابعك
ولكن الطبق العميق فكرة سيئة للغاية ،
سأصنع أعداء بين عشية وضحاها ،
فأنا أفضل القشرة الرقيقة سواء أكانت طبقًا عميقًا أم على
طراز الحانة ، هل هذا ما يأكله سكان شيكاغو حقًا
أم  هل هو كلب شيكاغو ،
ما هو الشيء الكلاسيكي ، فما الذي
نضعه على أي منها ما هو الخيار ،
كل شيء باستثناء المخللات لم
يعجبه أبدًا المخللات ، ما زالوا مثل المخللات
لن يحبوا المخللات
أبدًا.  سيقول dy أنه ليس كلبًا حقيقيًا في
شيكاغو بدون المخللات ، لذا
سأحصل على واحد منهم كيف
تأكله
[موسيقى]